we can't put a pad on until august 17th
it's funny that's my birthday so what a
great day that will be
i've never heard anyone say birthday
like that that's my birthday
my birthday happy happy birthday john
gruden
57 i'm old enough to remember when he
was a young head coach
i guess that means i'm pretty old too
nevertheless happy birthday john gruden
and your present is you get to put the
pads on you get to drive that ferrari a
little bit hopefully not too many of
those ferraris get nicked up once they
start hitting each other
chris uh you go if you if go ahead give
give john gruden your best happy
birthday wish
hey johnny johnny gruden johnny g happy
birthday man 57 years old holy cow i
can't believe it
i mean i believe i don't know why i mean
i'm pretty sure my rookie year there was
when he was gonna turn
40. so it's just shocking to go like
damn
you know he's 57 he's going to be 60
soon which means
you know to echo your sentiment i'm
getting old
because damn is life flying by holy cow
but
uh hey i had a lot of special times with
him i really did
he's a character unlike any other he
really is
i mean him showing up early in the
morning some of the laughs and jokes we
had through the years
uh they were you know priceless memories
so happy birthday to him
sources close to me tell me someone's
turning 40 in a couple of saturdays i'm
not quite sure who
continuing to research that very
carefully yeah yes
life is indeed flying by quickly it may
be flying by for derek carr life is a
starting quarterback because
john gruden has the wandering eye and
it's wandered on to
backup marcus mariota signed to a
one-year seven and a half million dollar
deal after the titans moved on to ryan
tannehill
so far so good for mariota here's john
gruden from
friday gushing about his new backup he's
interesting he took off a couple times
today really fired me up he's been hurt
uh looked like the ankle has really
turned the corner
uh he's he's a dazzling playmaker with
his feet
and that's the key to his game so i saw
that glimpses of that today it was
exciting
started off slow in seven on seven but
picked it up had a nice day
had a really nice day
dazzling playmaker with his feet now
look at a press conference you only can
answer the questions you're asked no one
asked him about derek carr so
it's not like he had a chance to say
anything about car that we could compare
and contrast
but it's not like john gruden has been
spontaneously throwing bouquets at his
starting quarterback and i just feel
like chris this is part of that broader
effort
to try to to poke and prod and the red
hot poker as you say it to just try to
coax more out of derek carr to get him
upset
wes welker style get him pissed off and
get him to go out and play better and i
feel like between the things lincoln
kennedy who's a raiders employee said
about derek carr
yeah the things mike mayok the raiders
gm has said about derek carr
the things gruden is saying about
mariota i feel like there's a broader
play here
to try to just stick at the car to get
carr
to play it as high as possible uh i mean
100 i don't think there's any doubt
about that
it's all you know you know like you're
saying a little needling
whatever it may be to motivate you know
keep him on his toes keep him driven
you know looking at the goal in front of
him whatever that is lincoln kennedy he
probably says that
why because he's around the raiders he's
probably heard the coaches echo those
sentiments i mean i don't know that
but that's how that world works a lot of
the time the local radio guy is at
training camp every day around the team
so he hears a lot of what the coaches
say
and want and you don't need you know and
then i think
you know just playing like you know
psycho analysis
type guy who's been around john gruden
hey
first off we know he loves the backup
quarterback always that's just the way
he is he is literally that meme
of like you know the guy walking down
the street the girl
his girlfriend's next to him and he's
checking out the other girl walking by
right i mean that's him
that's the way he's always been he's
always looking like oh
is the grass a little greener over there
i know i have peyton manning but
you know is somebody else better over
there i mean it wouldn't matter who was
there that's just the way he's wide
there it is there's johnny g see i was
that girl in the blue ones mike
i was that girl were you ever the girl
in the red ah remember the girl in the
room i was i was a little bit my second
year in the nfl he was looking at me
going
look at chris's legs and butt they look
good
[Laughter]
that would it was there is there any
quarterback where he wouldn't
behave that way i mean if he had tom
brady in his prime if he had peyton
manning in his prime i mean is there any
guy out there
that gruden would just say this is my
guy
forget about anyone else probably the
probably those
type of guys you know manning and brady
and that's about it
aaron rodgers i've heard him gush about
aaron rodgers before
you know where i think it's a very short
list
you know the story always was in the pro
bowl back in what was that 2001
his last year with the raiders john you
know rich gannon's you know mvp or mvp
candidate
and that you know he just drooled over
peyton manning the whole time
in front of rich gannon now one was
probably just the needle rich cannon
because
that's what john's gonna do just to keep
him motivated and do those type of
things but
two you know gruden was probably looking
at peyton manning and saw
film and does sees all the things he
does in the line of scrimmage and was
like oh i'd love to get my hands on this
guy
but he's obsessed mike with playmakers
and that's where i go back to that quote
where if i just go psychoanalysis you
know the foot the feet
the ability to be explosive and make
things happen
you know one i think that's what he's
looking more for
you know from derek carr as we've
mentioned in my quarterback rankings and
all that
hey derek carr let it go you know you
know let
you know fit some balls into some tight
windows make some aggressive decisions
hey nobody's open scramble around the
pocket
make a play run whatever it may be you
know mariota yes he can excite you
because he can
you know nobody's open he can tuck the
ball and turn the corner for 40 yards
and
offensive coordinator goes damn you know
that was a crappy play but i look good
thanks
you know thanks to that guy and i think
that's what he wants more from derek
carr
and it's probably why he's kind of
bringing those things out about marcus
mariota to kind of
you know say hey i like that and you
know hoping derek carr can hear that too
so your experience with gruden starting
17 years ago would suggest when he uses
the term
dazzling playmaker that's code of some
sort
that's a message yeah yeah yes dazzling
playmaker like you know oh when it's off
schedule
this guy you know i could still remember
um you know my i the year after i i i
lose
my spleen and jeff garcia coming in and
you know i'm not normal yet
i'm still trying to get my feet
underneath me and it's seven on seven
right there's no pass rush
but jeff garcia starts scrambling around
when people aren't open
and like we never did that before like
we never scrambled around like it was
still live even though like that was and
nobody had taught me that i hadn't seen
anybody do that since i was a pro
he did that i remember gruden just being
like oh out of way keep the play alive
and
way to make a play and do so you know
make it happen and i just remember
thinking then like oh wow okay he wants
more of that i need to infuse more of
that into my game i can just remember
how he
reacted to that and yes he's he's into
that mike it's
it's why we've talked about you know he
loved kyla murray the year before
you know because those guys you don't
always have to call the perfect play
they got enough ability as we've talked
about to make it happen when there's
nothing there to be made happen
probably goes back to gruden's time
working with brett favre in green bay
the guy
who would make things happen even if it
wasn't called now sometimes he made bad
things happen but the good outweighed
the bad
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports